well there's a lot of journalists have
really come a long way and understand
that the terminology is very important
so for example GLAAD was very
instrumental in for the the AP Stylebook
to be changed over time to where now the
word homosexual is really not used
except if it needs to be used in a very
clinical setting but really the gay and
lesbian are the terms that are used now
to talk about members of the gay and
lesbian community rather than homosexual
which immediately brings to mind
people's images of sexual relationships
and the LGBT community is is not just
about sexual relationships at all so
that was a very important thing and our
work with journalists over time has
really helped them understand how to
talk about the LGBT community I would
tell them and ask them to not allow
people to use their religious based
views as an excuse for their own
defamation and their own discrimination
because that's really what happens
someone will say well these are my
deeply held religious beliefs and very
few reporters will push back and say
well those deeply held religious beliefs
coming from the same place we're deeply
held religious religious beliefs
justified slavery in this country for
many years those deeply held religious
beliefs justified women not being able
to vote and women not having a place in
our society so those deeply held
religious beliefs there's very little
pushback to people about them because
we're afraid to do that and I think we
can respectfully have the conversation
and respectfully people are entitled and
should have their own deeply held
religious beliefs but those deeply held
religious beliefs are not supposed to be
portrayed as the view of our national
government they're not supposed to be
inherent in the way our society treats
all of us life liberty the pursuit of
happiness it should be every American's
opportunity not Jo's with not just those
of a few people or a group of people who
have deeply held religious beliefs in
this corner
there are others who have deeply held
religious beliefs in other corner